[Music]
[Applause]
now
ariel helwani he covers the uh
sport of mma ufc for the mothership and
uh he was uh
there to cover the conor mcgregor fight
this weekend
dustin poirier and uh he's set to join
us here on the program more phone calls
coming up
as well uh what did you expect to happen
this weekend ariel
if i'm being honest i expected conor
mcgregor to win that fight and that's
that's no knock on dustin poirier i just
thought
considering how their first fight went
six and a half years ago and considering
how connor looked and how he felt and
what he was saying i thought he was
going to win but
i'm not surprised and it really bothered
me to hear the disrespect that dustin
was getting leading up to this fight
because i think a lot of casual fans
just tuned in for connor fights and they
say oh he beat him
six and a half years ago in less than
two minutes it's gonna be a cake walk
dustin poirier is one of the ten best
fighters on the planet
and no one should really be shocked by
what he did on saturday but if you're a
casual fan
should you want to know more about
poirier or the condition of mcgregor
as he moves forward in his career i mean
obviously
conor's the biggest star in the history
of the sport so i think his next move is
probably what's of most interest to fans
um
you know we live in this culture one
thing that really bothers me is
especially with fighting
um you know these memes and stuff of him
being you know
knocked out on the ground and uh mocking
the fighters and stuff like that like i
think people are reveling
in his quote-unquote demise i think i
was on your show
the monday after his first fight um his
first loss to nathan diaz and everyone
back then in 2016 was reveling in his
demise what did he do he dusted himself
off and he won the rematch so
i suspect the same thing will happen
here he's embraced the bad guy
right uh honestly if you're the villain
the villain how's that you know what in
the
in the in the past yes but the last year
or so
we have seen a change in his demeanor
and in his character so to speak uh
first of all like this fight started
with him pledging to donate
500 000 to dustin's charity dustin has
this
amazing charity in louisiana called the
good fight foundation where he
he builds playgrounds and helps kids
less fortunate so that's how this really
started so he is donating 500 000
he's done a lot for his community back
home in ireland he i mean if you look at
the talk leading up to the fight there
was no trash talk if you look at the
video
and the scenes after the fight no trash
talk hugging saying i'm i'm happy
for you so this isn't the connor who
fought floyd
he's trying to change now if he fights a
guy like khabib who he
intensely hates i suspect the old conor
could come back
yeah that's but that is that good for
the sport that conor mcgregor is
the new and improved conor mcgregor so
leading up to this fight i had a lot of
people say like oh i missed the trash
talking connor right like i want the
showman i want the
the braggadocious guy who's going to go
out there and hurl these insults
i personally think that he fights better
this way but
maybe there's something to be said for
going back to the old connor maybe
there's something to be said for
that guy who was you know poking the
bear trying to climb the ladder trying
to get everyone's attention maybe that
gave him a little umph
i feel like that's looking into it a
little too much but yes there's no doubt
about it people fell in love with this
guy
not because he was donating money to his
opponent's charity they fell in love
with him
because he was you know calling people
names and and and pretty much turning
the whole sport upside down so yes
there's absolutely a point to be made
there
did khabib get uh mcgregor's attention
do you think
when he kind of called like i'm trying
to understand this
because he's just saying basically hey
come on you know you got something to
say come on in let's
you know if i'm khabib i'm going like
why
yeah so you know this whole thing has
been sort of blown out of proportion
you recall back in uh july of 2010 at
the boys and girls club in stanford
connecticut there was something
dubbed as the decision you remember that
right i i vaguely recall that yes
yeah we found out if lebron likes to
bite his nails and all that stuff well
um this was worse than that decision i
never thought i'd see a worse decision
than the one in 2010 but what they've
done with habib has been worse because
there is no decision to be made
this guy has been very clear about his
intentions
his father passed away his mother who
he's very close to has said i don't want
you to fight without your father by your
side
and he is respecting that we need to
leave the guy alone we need to let him
go off unto the sunset if he wants to
come back in two years great
but take the belt away vacated to be
honest this fight on saturday should
have been for the vacant title
and so i don't think he's coming back i
don't think he was coming back if conor
won
and i certainly don't think he's coming
back now that dustin poirier won because
he beat the semporia in 2019 there's
really no reason no
no purpose for him to come back at this
time and i wish they would just leave
him alone
how would you sum up the last 10 months
for ufc
oh my gosh uh it has been a whirlwind uh
so as you know they were the first ones
to come back they wanted to come back in
april
uh they were told to stand down by
disney in the state of california
dana white forged on um much of the
chagrin of some he put on the events in
florida and then in in vegas and in abu
dhabi
i think that as a result of being first
and though they rolled the dice and i
even had reservations about them coming
so soon coming back so soon in the
pandemic
they have they have earned a lot of new
fans
and a lot of people who never spoke to
me about mma friends family neighbors
now love the sport because in may june
and july there was nothing going on
there was nothing to gamble on
and they fell in love with the sport so
the ufc capitalized on that and if you
if you you look at the numbers for this
pay-per-view they're saying 1.6 to 1.8
million
that's a smashing success when does a
fighter get old in in ufc
well you know uh my co-host daniel
cormier
is a 41 and he just retired uh and he
was a two-time olympian
so it depends on your your career it
also depends on the damage that you take
you know there's a lot of guys who get
into these
fire fights each and every time they
fight and come 31 32
33 they start to slow down you have
other guys like khabib
who's in his early 30s who's taken
almost no damage throughout his career
and i suspect he could fight into his
40s
conor this was his first time that he'd
ever been kayode or tko'd he had never
really taken this kind of damage in a
fight i mean of course he'd been
submitted but that's different right
so i was saying you know if he still
wants to do this he could do this into
his late 30s
so it really depends i mean one of the
greatest fighters of all time randy
couture
started fighting in his mid 30s and went
into his
mid-40s so it's it's not quite like
baseball basketball football where
you know you start when you're early 20s
and then you're kind of done by your mid
to late 30s it's a little different in
that regard i was talking to the wife
last night and we were wondering where
we could take the kids
and i was wondering can you vacation on
fire fight i don't
think island uh if you have a lot of
money
and also uh if you i think if you have
some connections
uh you know fight island is not really
like a fight it's
just a place it's it's brilliant
marketing on their their part they have
been to quote unquote fight island
many times in the past in fact i was
there 11 years ago
it's yaz island in abu dhabi and you
know the the the geniuses at the ufc
dubbed it fight island and to their
credit it caught on but they did have
fans in attendance so people did
uh did fly in from all over they said
and uh
you know they had around 2000 for this
fight the prices were
astronomical like i think that the
cheapest ticket was like 2 000
2500 something like that so yes you
could go to abu dhabi dubai
and if you look at the scenes over there
it seems like they're handling the
pandemic a little better than we are
over here
but uh you're not really going to see
much if you go to quote-unquote fight
island because it's basically just an
arena and a hotel yeah as long as it's
all inclusive that's what my wife wanted
to know
you know like we could do a ground and
pound restaurant it could be like a
steakhouse yes
yeah the armbar i love that
uh great part of that off the top of my
head by the way no that's well done
hey i i would grab it i'd trademark that
thing the arm bar
let conor mcgregor know uh you know what
i think he's doing pretty well with his
whiskey and all his other endeavors i
might hold on to that one dana white
will probably watch this and
and steal it and trademark it within the
next 10 minutes though uh great to talk
to you ariel thanks for joining us as
always buddy
anytime thank you i like that the armbar
ariel helwani